WITH RESIGNATION OF THE CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE.
>> HE'S A REPUBLICAN, AND HE
JOINS US.
THANKS SO MUCH.
I CAN'T EVER REMEMBER THEM
CALLING FOR A RESIGNATION OF THE
CHAIRMAN.
>> YOU HAVE ADAM SCHIFF, AND ON
THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS COMMITTEE BUT
YOU DON'T KNOW THE MEMBERS
BECAUSE THEY KIND OF WORK UNDER
THE COVER OF DARKNESS.
THEY ARE FOCUSED ON IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA AND CHINA AND
TERRORISTS, AND IT'S VERY
BIPARTISAN, WORKING AT TO KEEP
AMERICA SAFE.
BUT YOU HAVE ADAM SCHIFF UP
THERE WHO IS NOT TAKING THE BOB
MUELLER REPORT WHO HE SAID IS A
GOLD STANDARD AND HE IS NOT
ACCEPTING IT.
HE'S OUT THERE TRYING TO UNDO
THE ELECTION FROM 2016.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE CRAZY
COMMENTATORS THAT GOT IT WRONG,
EVEN LOOK AT KLAPPER AND, THEY
WENT ON TV AND SPEWED THE LIVES
OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THE ONLY ONE WHO IS STILL
GETTING DAILY BRIEFINGS OR DAILY
JOBS WHO WAS INTELLIGENT WAS
ADAM SCHIFF.
THEN, YOU GO TO THE MEDIA AND
LIE ABOUT THAT INTELLIGENCE TO
PROMOTE THE STORY OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
HE'S LOST THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND HE NEEDS TO
STEP DOWN BECAUSE HE'S NOT
TRUSTED ANYMORE AND WE NEED TO
BRING THIS COMMITTEE BACK TO ONE
THAT WORKS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, GIVE UP THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
YOU HAVE HOLLYWOOD, YOU HAVE BIG
TECHNOLOGY, THE LIBERAL MEDIA
ALL TRYING TO TAKE DOWN
DONALD TRUMP.
WE SHOULD BE CELEBRATING TONIGHT
THAT THE AMERICAN SYSTEM
ACTUALLY WORKS.
AN INVESTIGATION HAPPENED AND,
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM IS ALIVE AND
WELL IN OUR COUNTRY.